[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN:
Welcome, everybody,
to our panel discussion on the
evolution of Asian cuisine.
I'm really happy to welcome
our guest chefs here
from the Asian Food Mafia, which
is a coalition of Asian chefs
and restaurateurs
based in New York City,
throughout the boroughs.
They kind of created this group
to help advance Asian cuisine
in the city, to
help each other out,
and also really to drive the
conversation on how Asian
cuisine will be evolving
in the city and beyond.
So I'll let the chefs
introduce themselves.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Sure.
I'm Chris Cheung, and I'm the
chef-owner of East Wind Snack
Shop in Brooklyn,
one in SoHo, and then
I also have Tansuo in
Nashville, Tennessee.
DORON WONG: My
name is Doron Wong.
I own Rivers and Hill
Hospitality Group.
We own and operate
Northern Tiger.
We have a farm in upstate
New York that does chickens,
USDA slaughterhouse.
We also have a project
in Austin, Texas,
called the General Tso'Boy.
EDWARD LIN: My name is Edward
Lin, along with my wife,
Lien Lin.
We're the chef-owners
of Bricolage,
modern Vietnamese gastropub
in Park Slope, Brooklyn.
MEDWIN PANG: Hi.
Medwin Pang, chef and
owner of Hunger Pang
in Flatbush, Brooklyn.
New American,
Asian-influenced, with a focus
on fresh and
seasonal ingredients.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: Cool.
So let's start with an easy
question for all of you,
or maybe not.
What-- kind of tell us--
walk us through quickly
what your story is, kind of
what brought you to the Asian
food scene in New York City,
and what brought you
to Asian Food Mafia.
CHRIS CHEUNG: OK.
So for me, I grew up in
Chinatown in Manhattan a long,
long time ago, and grew up as
an Asian-American eating lots
of Chinese food in
Chinatown, grew up on that,
with my grandmother and my
mother and the whole family.
And you know, we lived
that immigrant experience.
My grandmother and
grandfather came in to America
in the 1920s, and they settled
in a tenement in Chinatown,
and they had six kids, one
of them being my mother.
And we all grew up in that one
very small two-bedroom tenement
house on Mott
Street in Chinatown.
And my mother,
later on, moved out.
We moved to Brooklyn.
So I had kind of had the
American experience living
in Bensonhurst,
Brooklyn, at the time.
And if you can
tell, this accent,
I grew up with a lot of Italian
and Irish Americans out there.
And you know, I went
to school there.
But we'd always come
back to Chinatown.
That was always home,
coming back to Chinatown,
going out to eat
with the family.
And I grew up from
there, and became a chef
a little later on, and
used a lot of those
experiences I had to
influence my food.
Shooting all the way up to
kind of the present day,
last year I formed
the Asian Food Mafia.
I had opened up East
Wind Snack Shop.
And I made a lot
of friends when I
did that, so everybody included
here became a very good friend.
We're chef-owners of
Asian restaurants.
And I thought,
what a great idea.
You know, a lot of
us are out there now.
Asian food is a big deal now.
It's mainstream.
But we're all independent.
We're all solo.
We're all kind of
out there on our own.
And I thought we'd have a
bigger voice banding together,
you know, to do a
whole bunch of things.
Influencing the way Asian
food is doing right now
in New York City, that
was an important thing.
Another important
thing was to have
a voice about what it is
to be an Asian-American
and run a restaurant
in this city.
And then also just to hang out
with a bunch of chef friends,
and talk shop, and be able
to kind of get together
once a month and rant and rave
about what drives you crazy,
and to have some
support with that.
And these guys-- and we also
have a longer membership
of some guys that weren't
able to make it here today,
but we have a nice group of
about seven or eight chefs
that we get together, we
hang out once a month,
we plan events like this.
And you know, we
let off some steam.
So all cool stuff.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: Your story?
DORON WONG: Well, my story's
a little bit different.
I started in Boston.
I'm from Boston.
And I started when I was 14,
just for fun, just, you know,
when you're kids, you
just kind of figure
that you just want
to do something
to just get out of the house.
And I ended up getting a job
in this California bistro,
and I was making pizzas,
answering phones.
And it just kind
of created a lot
of curiosity of like, oh,
OK, how do you make that?
And you know, I was working
straight through high school.
Then I went-- you
know, I kind of
thought that that was
going to be my calling.
And I went to culinary
school, and right
after culinary school,
went to New York City,
because if you're going to
go anywhere in the world,
you're going to have to
come to New York City
and work with the best.
And I spent some time
with David Burke.
This is kind of like his
earlier years at Park Ave Cafe.
I don't know if you guys
know what Park Ave Cafe is.
And then I was there.
You know, being the
Chinese in the kitchen,
you're always being picked on.
Like, you know,
oh, he's Chinese.
Why isn't he cooking
Chinese food?
You know?
And it just kind
of made me think,
maybe I should actually
kind of learn my roots,
and I should go back
and cook Chinese food.
So I actually packed my
bags and went to Hong Kong.
I was like 18 years old.
And I went to Hong
Kong, spent time
in the kitchen in Hong
Kong, Singapore, you know,
got beaten down.
You know, even in the United
States, we're Chinese,
and then when we're
in Asia, we're--
they called me-- this
is funny, because they
called me "banana," because
I was literally white,
but I'm yellow.
You know?
So you know, it's
trying to fit in.
Came back to New York, worked
at a bunch of places, you know,
United Nations.
And then I was like,
you know, I think
I really need to really
concentrate on one thing
that I feel very
passionate about.
And that's how I
actually started
to do very regional
Chinese cooking.
And that's kind of
what really drove me
into what we do right now.
Especially with the
support group, you know,
it's a lot easier.
LIEN LIN: Well, I'm--
my parents are refugees.
I'm a refugee from Vietnam.
My parents fled to Hong
Kong, where I was born,
and then we were sponsored
to the United States
by a Catholic church.
And my parents ended up
doing restaurant work here,
because, you know,
they were uneducated,
came from a really
small town in Vietnam.
And so I grew up in the
restaurant industry.
And all my memories,
fondest memories,
was surrounded by
food and family.
That's where I was most happy.
And both my parents
cook, so I decided
to follow in their
footsteps, which, of course,
they were not happy about
when I was a teenager.
And I'm just very
passionate about food.
I want to stay
close to my culture,
because I've already
lost the language.
My parents coming here
to the United States,
they wanted to learn
English, and so
they didn't speak
to us in Chinese,
so we would learn the language.
And this is the way I
connect to who I am,
and I don't want to lose that.
And so then I went into
the restaurant industry,
worked with Charles Phan at the
Slanted Door for over 10 years.
And then my husband and
I made our way over here
and we opened our first
restaurant in Brooklyn.
And we're very happy to
be a part of this group.
And I think, yeah, all our
voices banding together really
help propel, or change
what we're trying to do
with Asian food culture here.
EDWARD LIN: I grew up in kind of
like Santa Cruz and Palo Alto,
in California, where your
other part of Google is.
But I actually grew up--
it wasn't so connected
with food and everything.
It was an academic science
background from my dad.
And I went through college,
and at some point, something
kind of clicked in my head,
and said, you know what?
I don't know if I
want to work in a lab
or work on a computer
for the near future.
LIEN LIN: It was fate
that brought us together.
We met in culinary school.
Yeah.
EDWARD LIN: I went
to culinary school.
I saw her there the first
day, and I was like, aah!
LIEN LIN: We fell in love,
and the rest is history.
A restaurant and two
kids later, here we are.
EDWARD LIN: But I worked
in some of the best fine
French kitchens,
even with Daniel Humm
when he was over
in San Francisco.
And at some point,
I met Charles,
and started working at
Slanted Door as well.
Learning about Asian
cuisine, learning
about a different way of
kind of looking and thinking
about how cuisine--
how food fits with the culture
and the history of the culture
is like, a lot of the
history of a culture
is really based on its food.
And definitely it's been an
evolution of thought there.
MEDWIN PANG: Right on.
OK, well, I'm going to take
it back before my time.
My father is from Hong Kong.
We have a little village
there, [INAUDIBLE],,
in the Fanling area in
the New Territories.
My father had to flee Hong
Kong for whatever reasons.
I don't know.
Being a British colony, UK
passport, ends up in the UK,
where he meets my mom.
They do a few things there.
He had a couple of restaurants.
And then one was blown
up by the IRA, which
we took the insurance money
and then moved to Brooklyn
when I was just a month old.
And then my father was, like,
a purveyor to restaurants.
He supplied restaurants
with, you know,
all their wares and
goods and everything.
And my mother worked in
the hospitality industry,
like in hotels, like the
Plaza, Waldorf Astoria.
So I'm coming from two
different sides, right?
Like, there was the food
side and then there was the,
I guess, the upscale
world of hospitality.
And being super fortunate
to be in New York,
I got my start when I was 17.
And I worked in a few kitchens.
And then I was looking for a
job, and just by dumb luck--
I didn't even know what
three-star food was--
I walked into Park Avenue Cafe
and dropped off my resume,
and they brought me in.
I thought I was going
in for an interview.
So I was wearing, you know,
like a button-up shirt
and everything.
And they're like, no,
you're here to cook.
And so they threw me whites
and I was like, oh, OK.
And got in, got
the job, and then
that was my entrance
into fine dining.
Hopped around from
different restaurants.
And starting so young, working
14 hours a day for years,
and not having any
holidays-- like,
Thanksgiving didn't exist,
Christmas didn't exist,
New Year's didn't exist.
Like, you're kind
of like a myth.
You don't really exist.
You only exist in
your work, right?
And so when I was 27, I was
kind of a little bit burnt out.
And so I left the restaurant.
So I was doing graphic
design as a hobby,
and the timing was perfect,
because a buddy of mine
just took over the art
director's position
at this startup, at the
time called Vitamin Water.
So he asked me if I
wanted to come on board,
and I did, and I was
doing print production.
I was doing all packaging,
labels, and all of that.
And then Coca-Cola
came in, took us on,
and so I stuck with them for
a number of years, you know,
for obvious reasons.
They take care of
their employees,
like I'm sure you guys are
well taken care of now.
And then layoffs happened.
I got hit by a round.
And where we live, my wife
and I, she was like, well,
you know, you have an idea.
You're only happy when you're
talking about food-- eating
food, cooking food.
And this neighborhood
needs something.
We have a concept.
Let's see if we
can make it happen.
Stars align, shop becomes
available, and then next thing
you know, Hunger Pang exists.
And here we are, three
years in, and yeah.
I mean, it was really--
it was stressful,
because I mean,
I'm completely independent.
It's only me and my wife.
We don't have any
investors, no partners
to share the responsibility.
So everything falls on me.
So when Chris came
up with this idea,
and thought of this
group, like, it was.
Like, for me, at first, I
was like, wait a second.
There's other people that
are going to understand
exactly what I'm dealing with?
And that first
night that we met,
we all just clicked
immediately, because it is.
It's really-- it's
special to have--
I mean, because what we do is
so unique, and it takes so much
of your time, and
there's not a lot
of people that
understand what we do
and the amount that
it requires from you.
So to have people that know
what you're going through really
is wonderful.
So yeah, that's my story, and
that's how I ended up here.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: Thank you
all for sharing your stories.
Sounds like quite a
diverse group, and quite
a diverse number of
backgrounds and reasons
for jumping into the
restaurant industry.
I think a common
thread that I'm hearing
is you all kind of stumbled
into AFM, Asian Food Mafia,
and found that it was just
really helpful to you.
Can you tell me
a little bit more
about what the group has done
for you, as a restaurateur,
as a chef?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Well, as Medwin
was kind of just alluding to,
as anybody who has ambitions
to be great in the restaurant
business, at some
point in your career,
you find yourself alone.
You know, your family is
there, but they don't really
understand what you go through--
the long hours, the
dedication to cooking.
There's many facets to
the restaurant business
that you have to put your hands
into when you start to become--
and run your own place.
So you do find yourself out
there by yourself, alone,
and having to deal with
a lot of the stresses.
And you're talking money stress.
You're talking about the
everyday stress of what
happens in a restaurant.
You know, a water pipe busts.
The garbage didn't
get picked up.
One of the cooks
doesn't show up.
And this happens
on a daily basis.
So you find yourself looking
for ways to kind of relieve
some of these things.
And you know, life
is life, right?
So you find yourself
really-- kind of you
take it as it comes,
and you keep going,
and you just keep going forward.
But I think what
Asian Food Mafia has
done, in an intangible way--
you know, there's tangible
things that we've done.
We do events, and we've done
some things for charities.
And we'll get to that
in a few minutes.
But intangibly, what it's
done for each one of us
is let us have an avenue
to figure some things out
with like minds.
And when you put on top of
that that we're also kind of--
we share the same
origins of culture,
and we've kind of gone through
the same things as Asians
in this business that are kind
of unique to our own problems,
it definitely is a good
thing to kind of be
able to pick up the phone,
or send a text or a message
and be like, can you
help me out with this?
Or can you help
me out with that?
And everybody in the group
will respond with the way
that they think that
they can help you.
And when you do find yourself
alone in this business
and know that you can rely on
some really good friends that
know exactly what
you're going through,
it makes for a really,
really cool thing.
So that's, you know.
LIEN LIN: Yeah, I think
definitely the support part
of it-- emotionally,
mentally, and physically--
has helped all of us make
it through a day or two.
Even if it's like, oh, can
I borrow your dishwasher
who's off today, because
mine didn't show up.
Or, words of advice, sharing
purveyors and contact
information, has
been very invaluable.
And just sharing our stories
and our love and passion
for food, because opening a
restaurant is not about, oh,
I love to cook!
Let me open a restaurant!
It is nothing like
that, let me tell you.
DORON WONG: You're the
bookkeeper, you're the plumber,
you're the electrician.
LIEN LIN: When you're
knee-deep in the sewers,
scooping out because of the
flooding in the basement.
EDWARD LIN: I mean, it's
kind of entrepreneurship--
well, it is absolutely
entrepreneurship.
But a restaurant
encompasses, I think,
every aspect of a
business, and usually
in such a small capacity
that you kind of
have to wear all these hats.
And that was something that
kind of drew me to the business,
is you're not just
focused on one thing.
You're focused on-- or
you're wearing every hat.
You're doing HR, PR,
finances, cooking,
mechanical,
electrical, plumbing.
LIEN LIN: Counseling.
EDWARD LIN: Counseling.
A lot of counseling nowadays.
Let me tell you, it's-- yeah.
LIEN LIN: Millennials.
EDWARD LIN: Hand-holding
cooks, and babysitting,
and getting everyone into a good
mental morale, a nice morale
space.
That really is such a key
part of running the business.
LIEN LIN: Or trying to
run a successful business.
EDWARD LIN: And then finding
a way to get your message out
there so that people
come, because especially
in New York, that's
the hardest part.
MEDWIN PANG: And aside from
the challenges that we can all
help each other with, and being
part of that support group, one
of the, I guess,
more enjoyable things
that we get to do together
is, during our meetings,
every so often, we'll do it in
each one of our restaurants.
And I think the last
one was at my place.
Was it at my place?
Yeah?
So when I'm thinking of
new dishes, I'm like, well,
you know, I ask my customers.
Like, I put out a
plate and I'm like,
what do you think of this?
And 90% of the
time, they're going
to tell you, oh, it's great,
without any real, critical
feedback.
But being surrounded
by your peers,
if I put a dish
in front of them,
I remember each of
their critiques on it.
So you get great
feedback from things
that you're trying to
work on and develop.
And also, when you
go to other houses,
you can be inspired by things
that the rest of the group
are doing.
So yeah.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah, we've
gotten close, very close,
over the last couple
of years, where
as a chef, when you're the
chef of your own restaurant,
you have people under
you that are great cooks.
But to kind of band together
with a group of really talented
chefs that are on
your level and we're
all kind of rising up together,
that's a really, really
cool thing to have.
Everybody kind of likens it,
you know, when we were kids,
you wanted to join a band.
And you listen to
the great musicians,
and they all kind of come
together and they play.
When we do events,
it's kind of like that,
when you kind of look over
and you see five or six really
good chefs that
are on your level,
and you're all cooking together,
and you all kind of have
the same thing going
forward, the same goals.
And then the same
goals long-term
for your restaurant,
but the same goals
for the instantaneous moment
of how food comes out.
And when you're
cooking together,
it's one of those things that
kind of really gets you going,
gives you a rush.
And you kind of hold onto
that rush for a while.
DORON WONG: It's funny
because a lot of people
would think we're supposed
to be competition, you know?
Especially these guys are
in the same neighborhood,
but shouldn't you
guys be competitive?
CHRIS CHEUNG: We
have customers, I
have customers, that come in
and rave about his restaurant,
and say he's one of the
favorites that they go to.
And I'm glad.
I'm really happy that we can
share a customer base that's
happy with both our spaces.
DORON WONG: Yeah, I'm also very
glad that it's not about doing
better than the other person.
It's about-- because
I feel like we're
a little bit behind in the Asian
food, that we're able to kind
of elevate it together.
I think a lot of people
really do understand
that Chinese food and--
I can say "Chinese food," right?
Yeah.
Chinese food.
People don't pay for
Chinese food, right?
Especially, I had this problem
when I had a restaurant called
Yunnan Kitchen.
And everyone's like, aw,
man, your place is so small.
And why is this
different than Chinatown?
How can Chinatown--
you actually have
a plate of noodles
that's, like, $5,
and it's four times your size?
And for us, I think
we're all trying
to kind of elevate what we do.
We're using clean food.
I think a lot of it is clean.
I know they push a lot of
clean, sustainable food as well.
And we're doing that
together, as a group.
It's very hard to change
people's perception
of what Chinese food is,
especially Chinese food.
You know, everyone thinks ghetto
Chinese food is General Tso
chicken with this yellow
fried rice, and it's--
MEDWIN PANG: In a
Styrofoam container.
DORON WONG: Yeah, and it's got
to have a can of Coke for $5.
LIEN LIN: Vietnamese
food is banh mi and pho.
But there's so much
more to Vietnamese food.
There are so many dishes
and different regions
of the cuisine that people
haven't explored yet.
And to be able to serve it in
the kind of setting that we
serve it in, and the beverage
program that we offer
alongside with the food, is
just a different experience
that I wanted to bring
to the neighborhood.
EDWARD LIN: I mean, it's
definitely one thing.
You know, you can go to a
pizza-by-the-slice joint
and get a slice for $1.
You can go to Roberta's and
buy a pie for $20-something.
And one is not the
same as the other.
And the same thing
with Asian food.
A take-out Asian place versus
one of our restaurants,
or other restaurants
that are really
trying to push good
quality food, good service,
good atmosphere and
decor and everything,
they're two completely
different things.
And while a lot of
people might say
that this dish is
expensive, but if you
take that same amount of--
like, a pork chop, right?
You take a pork
chop, same amount
of meat, same cut, same
purveyor, same farm, and you
go to a New American place and
you say, OK, $27, no problem.
You go to an Asian
place, wow, $27.
That's like-- you know, I can
get it for $12 at Chinatown.
Yeah, but they're
buying commodity meat.
They're giving you
a thin, crappy pork
chop, or whatever it is.
It's a completely
different item,
and it should be
compared with cuisine
from any culture that's doing
at the same kind of level.
Same thing with
atmosphere and decor.
And a lot of what you actually
pay for in a restaurant
is an experience, is service,
is decor, music, lighting,
and just being able to go
there, have a good time, relax.
And that's worth
something, versus going
into a fluorescent-lit--
LIEN LIN: Which is a
great experience too.
EDWARD LIN: Which can
also be a lot of fun.
LIEN LIN: It is.
It depends on the
mood and the day.
Like, I love going there
and eating that food too.
But I think that to get
together as Asian Food Mafia,
we are trying to
elevate that experience
at an Asian restaurant.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: So
I mean, definitely it
sounds like one
of the challenges
with Asian food in New
York, and I think elsewhere,
is kind of the stigma
associated with Asian food.
It makes it more
difficult to open and have
a successful Asian restaurant.
What are some of the
ways in which, I think,
being in the Asian cuisine space
has helped or inspired or kind
of changed how you've
run your restaurant
and how you've set the goals
for yourself as a chef?
LIEN LIN: That's still working.
I mean, I always--
when it comes down to
it, I always look deep
inside my heart
and feel like this
is the story I want to share.
This is something that's
near and dear to my heart,
because this is my
culture and my family.
And I want to be able to
share it with the world,
or that's what I'm trying to do.
EDWARD LIN: I mean, I think--
while we did choose to
open Asian restaurants,
I think that really
they chose us,
because of our
culture and heritage.
I mean, we've all worked
in Western restaurants.
I worked for years in fine
French and Park Ave Cafe,
and you've worked in
Jean-Georges and everything.
So we've seen the American
side, the French side.
And we've done that
and are perfectly
capable of opening a French
bistro or an Italian place or--
we're all talented
chefs, and we're all
perfectly capable of doing it.
But this is a culture that
in one way or another,
we came up in.
And so it kind of chooses
you, almost as a way.
But it's something
that you definitely
want to turn around and be
able to share and expand
people's understanding of
the food and the culture,
and kind of also
help evolve it, too.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah, I
think as Asian food goes--
whether it's Chinese,
Vietnamese, a mix--
it's mainstream now.
There's a lot of interest in it.
But I don't like what
you were talking about as
far as price points.
I don't think it's hit
its sweet spot yet,
in terms of point of views.
So while somebody can
have a dollar slice
and still appreciate
paying $30 for a Di Fara's
pizza or a wood-fired-oven
pizza, some of that
hasn't translated over to
Asian food yet as well.
And there is-- no
matter how well
you cook, no matter what kitchen
you've been brought up in
and how much you stick to
that discipline of using
great ingredients, using
technique that is, I guess,
kind of connected to
going the extra mile
in the kitchen,
some of that doesn't
get appreciated as well.
And people just kind
of stick to what
they've known for
food in Chinatown,
food on the lower-end scale.
So you know, [INAUDIBLE]
still hasn't been told.
And that's why we're here.
And we're doing our best to
try to make that a thing,
and to stand out and say,
hey, it's the 21st century.
There's lots of Asian
people in America.
people in New York City.
And we can make this food in
the image that we want to,
and the way we were
brought up with it,
and it doesn't always just have
to be $3 orders in Chinatown.
It can be something else.
I'm not kind of comparing it in
terms of better, because when
I'm getting off of
work, I go to Chinatown,
and I love eating in Chinatown.
I love eating in Koreatown.
I love that food.
But when you have
your restaurant,
and you want to make
the food you want to,
but you want to incorporate
the things you grew up
loving to eat and grew
up loving to cook,
but you have all these other
things in front of you,
like great sustainable
responsible ingredients,
like a brigade of cooks that
have an ambition to cook things
with the higher
technical skill, you
want to bring those
things together.
I mean, that's a great thing.
You want to show that off.
And there are certain stigmas
in the culture of this city
and in the culture
of this country that
are kind of not letting
that happen quick enough.
So that's one of our goals,
is to kind of speed up
that evolution of food,
in terms of Asian cuisine.
So, you know, and I think
we're getting there.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: What
are the changing-- or, yeah.
Go ahead.
DORON WONG: Well, there's
little exceptions.
Like, people will pay $300 a
head for sushi, no problem.
But they won't pay $300
a head for Chinese food.
And that's really what
we're trying to do.
EDWARD LIN: Yeah.
And we've discussed
this as a group.
We've really thought about it.
We've had some
articles and reporters
talk to us about, like, what
do you think about these--
why that is?
And you know, it
does come back to--
we've thought about it.
It kind of comes
back to the culture
of how a certain
culture was brought
to America, how a certain--
like, whether it was
refugees that came across
or whether it was--
like, in the case
of Japanese cuisine,
a lot of American
soldiers went to Japan
and experienced Japanese
cuisine at its finest,
and then came back
with a taste for sushi
and an understanding
of the quality,
whereas with a lot of Chinese
and South Asian cultures,
it's refugees that came across.
It was-- like, in
the case of Chinese,
it was workers that came
across and worked on railways.
And they brought what they
could of their cuisine,
but had to change it for local
reasons, for local tastes.
And that's really
where the birth
of American Chinese
cuisine is from.
You go to China, there's
no Kung Pao chicken.
There's no-- I mean,
General Tso's chicken.
Have you seen "Searching
for General Tso?"
There is no General
Tso's chicken in China.
Just none.
There's no fortune
cookies in China.
None.
LIEN LIN: I love General Tso's.
EDWARD LIN: These
are things that are--
and sweet and sour pork is
a completely different dish,
completely 100% different.
And that's because the food
that is in the Chinese take-out
places, that's an American food.
It's sweet, it's fast, it's
kind of a guilty pleasure.
LIEN LIN: Yeah.
When my parents-- growing
up in a restaurant,
we had that Asian restaurant
in upstate New York.
And what they cooked
for the customers
and what we ate for family meal
was completely different food.
And I considered it two
different types of food.
And now that my-- and we
grew up in the restaurant.
And now my uncle--
my cousin makes sushi now.
And he's laughing all
the way to the bank.
He's like, I don't even
have to cook this stuff!
I just cut it and put
it on a piece of rice.
Way less work for him.
EDWARD LIN: But it's kind
of how the cultures got
introduced to the country.
And so when the initial
point of exposure
is cheap Chinese
food from a take-out,
then all Chinese food
becomes generalized,
and it becomes cheap.
When the initial
point of contact
is a high-end sushi
restaurant, then you
just expect sushi
to be expensive,
and you're OK with paying it.
Korean is kind of
halfway in between.
It can be expensive,
it can be cheap.
But definitely, Chinese,
South Asian, even Indian,
for the most part, it's
considered cheaper.
I mean, if you think
about Western cultures,
like, Mexican food has the same
kind of connotation, right?
There are some amazing Mexican
cuisines, or [INAUDIBLE],,
Central American
cuisines, but you
don't pay for it,
because you know,
tacos, burritos,
those are cheap.
And whereas like French,
yeah, you pay for it.
Italian, sure, you
pay for Italian.
But Italian's kind of halfway
there as well in Europe,
because you have
some cheap Italian,
you have some good Italian.
So really thinking
about cultures
and how they fit into the
economic structure of America
and all that, it's in the
back of your head kind of,
and you try to find
a way, all right,
how do we make this
more acceptable, more--
like, how do we make it better?
How do we make it something
that not just Asians in New York
appreciate, but everyone?
And you do that.
MEDWIN PANG: So obviously,
it's a pain point for our group
that Asian food,
Chinese food, is
expected to be less expensive
than any other food out there.
I have a 10-ounce grass-fed New
York strip steak on my menu.
But I only charge $30 for it.
That's because of where I am.
Where I am in Flatbush,
four blocks away, there's
Chinese take-out joints
that have, like, still
bulletproof glass
in them, you know,
where you can get a
lunch special for $4.
And you could feed two
or three people from it.
So yeah, I guess what
we're trying to do
is to erase what's been
ingrained in people's
head about what the
expectation is of Chinese food.
One being quality
of ingredients,
and second being price point,
and then another being service.
So it's like, OK,
if you step into--
and it's not only any
of our restaurants.
It's just like, if you step
into a new, modern place,
you have to approach
it with an open mind.
You can't carry any of
those stigmas with you.
Otherwise, you're
closing yourself
off from the experience.
So if you walk into a new place
that you haven't tried yet,
you don't know
anything about, you
have to have an open mind,
because if you already
have these
preconceptions of them,
then you're missing out
on the possibilities
that a place could do for you.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: Speaking
of preconceptions, I mean,
one of the things that kind
of was brought up repeatedly
is kind of the Chinese
food that people
are used to might not even
be the Chinese food that
kind of Chinese
people eat at home,
or kind of the immigrants
who came here actually
still eat at home.
So can you talk
a little bit more
about how you guys as, I think,
restaurant owners and chefs
kind of walk that line
between authenticity,
kind of innovation, and
also just cooking the food
that you're used to eating?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Well,
for me, actually, it
takes a different spin, because
I'm actually now grieving
over the loss of a
lot of restaurants
that I used to go to
that are now closed,
and a lot of [INAUDIBLE]
restaurants in Chinatown.
And so those type
of restaurants,
to go back to when I
grew up, in Chinatown,
my parents and my grandparents,
that whole community
came over in the early 1900s.
By the 1930s, '40s, '50s,
they all started businesses
in Chinatown, and
they all started
restaurants, some of
which became iconic
through the community
in Chinatown,
places that we always
would go to just to make
us happy with food.
And you go to today, and
most of those restaurants
are gone, because the
owners of those restaurants
lived the American dream.
So they worked hard.
They had children.
They worked really hard to put
those children into college.
Those children went
to college, grew up,
and now they're doctors
and lawyers and engineers
and professionals like that,
and the restaurant now is old.
The owner, who's the father
and the mother, are now old,
and they can't do the
restaurant anymore.
Who do they give
this restaurant to?
The kids don't want it.
Right, the kids are now
doctors and lawyers.
They do not want to
go back to Chinatown
and run and operate
a restaurant.
And so those restaurants
close and a new guard
comes into Chinatown.
You have this new stuff.
But I'm not ready to
let go of the old stuff
yet and move on
to the new stuff.
I still love those restaurants,
and I still really kind
of long to eat that food.
And so as a chef, I'm trying
to, in certain dishes that I do,
try to recreate that
experience for my customers,
just like it made me
happy as a kid growing up
eating that food in Chinatown.
So you know, it doesn't even--
you guys don't even notice
it, but you're saying
goodbye to an era in New York.
And this is happening in
the Chinese community.
It's happening in the Polish
community and the Eastern
European, in the Italian
community as well.
So it's happening to
all those immigrants
that kind of came up in
America at the same time.
But you know, and the
good news for some of us
is you're seeing a new
influx of food and cuisine
that's taking over.
So in Chinatown you have
the Fujianese, right?
So there's a new
couple of styles
of food, a lot of more northern,
Beijing, Shanghainese food.
If you go up to Flushing,
it's almost all northern food.
And then you have also
a new guard like us,
who have been here
and grew up American,
and are trying to incorporate
the Chinese and Asian food
that we grew up in, but
attaching it to our skills
as we've learned, climbing up
the ladder in the New York City
restaurant market.
So there's lots of cool
stuff going on too, but yeah.
When I go down to
Chinatown and I
see seven or eight
of the restaurants
that I used to go
all the time, you
know, I kind of
get a little tear,
because those days are gone.
LIEN LIN: Yeah, it's the
evolution of cuisine,
which is inevitable.
It's going to happen.
For example, because I
know Vietnamese cuisine,
the French colonized Vietnam
for many, many years.
So a lot of the food that--
a lot of the classical,
traditional dishes
actually have a lot of
French influence on them.
And then same with
my growing up too.
My parents were ethnically
Chinese, but they--
many, many generations
in Vietnam.
So when I was
growing up, I thought
I was eating Chinese food
because we identify as Chinese,
then come to realize when I'd
become a teenager, I'm like,
oh, well, this
isn't Chinese food!
This is a weird mash-up of
Vietnamese-Chinese food.
And so this is what I
serve at the restaurant,
because it doesn't exist.
EDWARD LIN: Well, it
exists in your family.
MEDWIN PANG: And like Ed
said before, we've all
worked in Western kitchens.
So there's no way that that
can't influence what we do.
No matter how hard you're trying
to be traditional or authentic,
there's always going to be
some kind of integration or--
CHRIS CHEUNG: And I think
all the Western restaurants
that we kind of came
up the ladder were
the old-school
restaurants, militaristic.
They broke you down.
So you'd get yelled
at, food thrown at you.
LIEN LIN: Like Gordon Ramsay.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Basically
you're abused.
But it does break
you down, and then it
becomes ingrained
in you what you
have to do to survive and
to do well in the kitchen.
So it's ingrained in
all of us from chefs
that were way better
than us at the time, that
just stood over you and just
knocked the crap out of you.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN:
Beat you down
so you could build yourself
back up again, right?
MEDWIN PANG: Doesn't
happen now, though.
You'd get sued.
LIEN LIN: It's a
different world.
EDWARD LIN:
Completely different.
LIEN LIN: I think all of us
are struggling with that, too.
This isn't the world
that we grew up with,
with the staff that
we're seeing these days,
and the cooks, the shortage of
cooks, especially in New York,
we have noticed.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: And on
that really intense note,
I do want to leave some
time for audience Q&A.
So if you have a question,
feel free to raise your hand.
And we don't have any mics,
but I can repeat your question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it seemed
like you guys have a lot
of relatively high-end food.
And I've found-- I'm
pretty into Asian food,
and I've found so many--
even though it is, like you're
saying, it's mainstream now.
But at the same
time, so many people,
they don't have a clue
what Szechuan food is,
or what a good
Chinese noodle is.
An amazing number
of people don't even
know what a banh mi is.
So I was just kind
of curious, you
didn't mention it that much,
how you're getting-- people just
don't try the food.
Besides just expecting
a cheap price,
I think people don't even
know what the food is.
Like, something
that tastes amazing,
they're not even willing to try.
So I don't know if
you guys as a group,
have you thought
about strategies
to get more people to try it?
CHRIS CHEUNG:
Well, one thing is,
you got to have a big bullhorn.
You have to have a voice
in these sort of things.
And so that's what
we're trying to do.
And we're speaking here
in places like this,
and hopefully we've touched on
a couple of buttons that maybe
drive you guys to want to
explore different avenues
of Chinese food.
And then, of course, you
know, the ultimate equalizer
is you have to back
it up with talent.
You got to make good food.
You got to make people
that want to try it.
This town is highly
competitive, and you
have to get your
voice out there,
because you have to kind
of put yourself apart
from everybody else.
And that's when they come try.
And then when they do
try, it has to be good.
So it's really simplistic for
us, and for me, as a chef,
to get that word out.
And it starts organically.
And then sometimes
you get some breaks,
and you get some good
things happening to you.
And that word spreads,
and the more the merrier.
So the more people
that have that voice
and are speaking out and saying,
come check out this food,
and come check out
what we're doing,
then the ball starts rolling
from there, at least for me.
LIEN LIN: Yeah, and
I think in New York--
I'm sorry.
In New York is a great
platform for this, too,
because it's just
so diverse here.
And there's so many cultures
that are coming together.
And I think people are excited
to learn about someone else's
culture through the food.
That's how I experience
other people's culture, is
the first time, it's
always through the food.
And that makes me excited.
MEDWIN PANG: I think
the question was,
people haven't been to China.
So how do they know
what authentic food is?
And how do we
plan, or do we have
a plan, to educate
people on what, say,
authentic Szechuan
food is, right?
AUDIENCE: No, or just to
get people to even try it.
I mean, I've been
to Yunnan Kitchen.
A lot of places,
they might be good,
and no one even steps foot in
it, regardless of the price.
MEDWIN PANG: Right,
because they don't
know what "Yunnan" is, right?
Like, what does that mean,
and why should I come in here
and try this?
Is that what you're asking?
Well, I mean, that's what
this group is all about.
I mean, we're trying to
raise our voice as one.
And we promote each other.
And that's pretty much
the whole plan, aside
from opening doors
and using social media
and doing events like this.
EDWARD LIN: I mean, this is the
thing about doing a restaurant
kind of in a modern--
like, for lack of a better
term, a Western way,
versus an old-school,
old Asian way.
You know, all those restaurants
that Chris was talking about,
the old-school
Asian restaurants,
or Chinese restaurants,
in Chinatown,
they didn't have social media.
They didn't have-- they had
a base of Chinatown residents
that came, and that was
their bread and butter.
Nowadays, you have to
market to everyone.
You have to do Twitter,
Facebook, Instagram.
LIEN LIN: Yeah, the Facebook
marketing is changing too.
EDWARD LIN: That's changing.
LIEN LIN: A learning
curve for all of us.
EDWARD LIN: And then just
the way that it's presented
is changing.
And that's kind of what--
we're not just a
Vietnamese restaurant.
We're not just a
Chinese restaurant.
We're part of-- we're showing
that we're doing everything
just as good as everyone else.
Actually, you walk
by most of our places
and it could be something else.
It could be a
Western restaurant.
You don't know.
And as soon as you go up to the
window and you read the menu,
you're like, oh, OK,
this is something
I haven't tried before.
Now, getting people
to try things
that they haven't tried before,
that's always difficult,
depending on the person.
I ask our six-year-old
if he wants to try this,
and sometimes he will,
and sometimes he won't.
And he's quite adventurous,
and so he'll eat fish eyeballs.
But you turn around
to someone else,
and they're like, no, I'm
not going to eat that.
But the more exposure,
I think, that people
get of the culture,
of the cuisine,
they become interested.
And I mean, I think
it's with anything,
once you try it a few times,
you're like, all right.
That was interesting.
I see where that's going, and
I want to try something more.
It's kind of like, the
first time you tried coffee,
it was horrifically
bitter and terrible,
and you loaded it up
with sugar and milk.
And then now, you can't live
without your $8 coffee--
shade-grown, organic,
and single-source--
because you've grown to
appreciate what is nice,
what is good about
certain things.
And with food, any good
chef will tell you,
there's a balance.
There's a balance of the basic
flavors, sweet, salty, sour,
and bitter.
And beyond that, texture and
umami and all those things.
But you can tell a good
dish when you try it.
You can tell, all right,
this noodle, it's got bounce,
it's got spring, and
it's lively in my mouth,
versus a noodle
that's like mush,
and this tastes like oatmeal.
That's not a good noodle.
But you know, the more you
try it, the more you're
going to find, all right,
this is actually good.
I like this more
and more and more.
And I'm going to find
better and better and better
versions of it.
And it just takes
experimentation.
And I think that's
part of, hopefully,
what this world
is growing to, is
that people look
at other cultures
and are interested in other
cultures beyond their own.
And then they start to learn
and accept other cultures,
and people get along better,
and the world's a better place.
CHRIS CHEUNG: By the
way, if anybody has not
tried any of our
restaurants, you guys
are totally invited to come
and check us out, for sure.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN:
We have time for one,
or maybe we can
try to fit in two.
It's you first?
AUDIENCE: So I think
[INAUDIBLE] seem
to be some of the high-end
restaurants in China opened
their franchise [INAUDIBLE],,
you can go se [INAUDIBLE]
and which was popular in
China, but [INAUDIBLE]
open a franchise
in Times Square.
So they also have very
good service and decor,
and also pretty
authentic food, I think.
But unlike you guys, they
have a really good connection
to the local culture and local--
well, their manager, owner,
or the chef, they just
everybody come from China.
So what do you think--
what's your opinion
on those kind of franchise?
Where do you think
they will have
impact on the ecosystem
of Asian restaurant
here in New York City?
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: Just
to repeat the question,
since it was a bit quiet.
So the question was about
restaurant franchises
that were high-end in China, but
are actually opening branches
here in America.
How does that impact
how you guys are
running your restaurants,
and how the Asian food
scene is in general?
DORON WONG: I think it's great.
You know, Chef Dong
has a Michelin star.
He's reached out to us to help
him with the local market.
We do-- I do wish him a lot
of luck, because it helps us.
It helps a franchise like
that, a Michelin star chef,
to come in here and say,
this is what Peking duck is.
And we're going to
charge you $100 a person.
And this is what
you're going to pay.
And this is the quality and
the standard that it is.
And it helps us,
it helps us a lot.
LIEN LIN: The louder the voice.
DORON WONG: Because of his
credibility, and credibility
that comes with it.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah.
I'm not sure 10,
15 years ago, he
would come with
that much bravado,
and be set up to
at least be set up
to be successful like what
looks like what's coming.
10, 15 years ago, it may
not have been a big thing,
or not even newsworthy.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: Let's
do one more question.
You?
AUDIENCE: I was--
I feel like one significant
exception to the [INAUDIBLE]
market is the sort
of fusion cuisine.
It appears now you're mostly,
at least not intentionally,
marketing yourselves
as that, and you
mentioned some of the
influence was unavoidable.
And I was kind of
curious how you
felt about that space, which
on the one hand kind of
has been really successful,
and the [INAUDIBLE]
experimentation, but
on the other hand,
does seem to be closely
targeting white people.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: So this
question about fusion cuisine
and how generally
it seems like it's
targeted at a
higher-end audience
and has been fairly successful.
And kind of how your
restaurant sits in that space.
MEDWIN PANG: Everybody
looking at me?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, well, the
whole fusion movement
was great, because if
it weren't for that,
then every Asian restaurant,
or any other fusion restaurant,
would just be whatever
the region that it's from.
Right, being that
it's fusion, it
makes it more
approachable to anybody.
So if they add flavors that
are familiar to the locals,
then they're going to
be more apt to try it.
So yeah, the fusion
thing was great,
though I hate the
term "fusion" myself,
because that came about
for lack of better words
to describe something.
And it was from Nobu, where
he does Peruvian and Japanese.
And it was in the review
that he was, like, oh, he
does this fusion thing.
So that term caught on.
But yeah, it's great,
just high-end chefs
from other parts of
the world, regardless
of where they're from,
coming here to New York
to elevate their cuisine.
Anything that builds
awareness is a good thing.
And without having
to cheapen yourself
by saying, oh, you know,
I'm not so authentic,
or I'm not so traditional,
because I add other influences,
doesn't take away.
It just makes it
more approachable for
the average Joe to understand.
EDWARD LIN: The one caveat is
to successfully fuse cuisines,
you have to understand both,
or whatever you're mixing.
And that's where, I
think, a lot of really--
where fusion got a kind
of a bad rap, in the '90s,
they were just fusing
kung pao macaroni
or something like that.
And if you really understand
the essence of whatever you're
putting together, then you can
pick out the best parts of it
and make it work on a palate
level, on a texture level,
and even on a
conceptual level, where
you have a history of the
dish, and it kind of gives more
reason for being.
I mean, Vietnamese itself
is a fusion cuisine.
It's a fusion of South
Asian and French,
like, naturally,
though, because--
LIEN LIN: And it took time.
EDWARD LIN: It took time.
It took generations
of French influence
and Asian influence
coming together.
CHRIS CHEUNG: That's such a cool
thing though, right, to happen?
EDWARD LIN: Yeah, that
is such a cool thing,
when it does happen.
LIEN LIN: But now
it's considered--
like, banh mis are considered
a traditional Vietnamese food.
EDWARD LIN: Yeah.
So fusion and innovation
isn't a bad thing.
It's only when it's
done wrong, when
it's done thoughtlessly
and carelessly,
that it becomes bad.
SUCHANAN AKSORNNAN: That's
actually all the time we have.
But thank you so much for
joining us and telling us
your stories.
If you have any
further questions,
I mean, all these chefs
are at their restaurants,
and you should definitely visit.
And I think that'll be it.
So thank you all for joining us.
LIEN LIN: Thank you so
much for having us today.
[APPLAUSE]